EU finance ministers meeting in
Luxembourg want to put flesh on the
bones of Europe's investment and girls
plans ministers will discuss concrete
measures to be presented by the
Commission and the European Investment
Bank to boost investment in projects
which could generate growth and jobs
ministers are also said to discuss a
commission communication on research and
innovation as sources of renewed growth
in the field of Taxation the council is
expected to reach political agreement on
a proposal aimed at the neighbouring
member states to better combat tax fraud
and tax evasion the idea is to extend
the scope of the mandatory automatic
exchange of information between tax
administration's to include also
dividends capital gains other financial
income and account balances ministers
will also debate a proposal to
restructure the taxation of energy
products and electricity to promote
energy efficiency and a greater use of
renewable sources the council will be
briefed by the Commission on the
preparation of implementing legislation
on contributions to be paid by banks to
resolution funds established under
recently agreed rules on bank resolution
under the new rules banks will have to
make annual contributions which will be
calculated on the basis of their
liabilities excluding own funds and
cover deposits and adjusted for risk